[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'actualités
locales nous allons faire le point au
cours du prochain quart d'heure sur les
principales informations de ce 3 octobre
voici les titres un parrain de prestige
pour le pèlerinage littéraire de la
maison zola mais dans françois hollande
a fait le déplacement il en a profité
pour adresser un discours qui laisse peu
de place au doute quant à sa candidature
pour 2010 est là des animations
gratuites de jour comme de nuit pour
porter un nouveau regard sur la pratique
du golf c'est l'objectif du golfe
festival qui vient de se refermer à
saint quentin en yvelines et puis ils
sont adeptes de jeux vidéo anciens des
jeunes et surtout des moins jeunes ne
jure que par le rétro gaming une
exposition est même consacré au
phénomène attrape en ce moment on débute
tout d'abord cette édition par le
déplacement du président de la
république hamedan dans les yvelines ce
week-end françois hollande était
l'invité du pèlerinage littéraire de la
maison zola il a rendu hommage à
l'écrivain auteur du célèbre article
j'accuse sans perdre de vue pour autant
à la campagne présidentielle de 2017
anne-laure l'anguille sur des images de
nos confrères divine première
c'est aux côtés de sa ministre de la
culture audrey azoulay que françois
hollande a inauguré hier la réouverture
de la maison d'emile zola fermé pour
travaux depuis 2011 l'écrivain avait pu
s'offrir cette demeure grâce au succès
de son roman l'assommoir dans une
allocution de près d'une demi heure le
président a rappelé les combat humaniste
de l'écrivain mentionnant à plusieurs
reprises l'espoir qu'il avait nourri
toute sa bulle même dans la nuit la plus
sombre lui toujours une espérance même
dans l'engrenage d'une machinerie
infernale
il suffit d'une voix une seule pour
changer le cours des choses et le destin
des hommes une perspective que le
président pourrait bien souhaité pour
lui même à quelques mois de la fin de
son mandat en conclusion comme un écho à
son propre parcours
il a tenu à rappeler l'essence même de
tout combat politique voilà notre
responsabilité face à l'histoire ne pas
s'abandonner à la fatalité à la facilité
avoir le courage de faire le choix
justes qui n'est pas toujours le plus
populaire ou le plus gratifiant d'autres
personnalités invitées ont aussi rendu
hommage au grand homme en prenant
justement fait et cause dans l' affaire
dreyfus il a donné ses lettres de
noblesse et les lettres de noblesse donc
à la république qui s'était quelque peu
égaré un magnifique discours en
l'honneur des d'emile zola et de son
combat pour la république la justice
contre toutes les formes d'intolérance
de discrimination
prévu à proximité de la maison zola un
musée dreyfus devrait ouvrir ses portes
en 2018
et puisque l'on parle politique du côté
des républicains à présent on a inauguré
la nouvelle permanence des yvelines
samedi pour l'occasion une soixantaine
de militants étaient présents avec les
élus de david douillet député président
de la fédération départementale à
valérie pécresse présidente du conseil
régional d'île de france les
républicains dont toute l'attention se
focalise sur cette primaire de la droite
dans le département tout est prêt nous a
assuré la sénateure sophie primas nous
avions des échéances à respecter trouver
d'abord les bureaux de vote dans
l'ensemble des îles à 264,2 mi-noir
trouver ensuite les présidents dans
chaque bureau de vote puisse y trouver
des équipes qui animeront le 20 et le 27
novembre c'est permanence et ses bureaux
de vote ont l'ensemble des vidéos tout
ça est organisée tout ça est aujourd'hui
validée par par le comité d'organisation
des primaires et nous sommes nous sommes
d'attac nous passons maintenant à cette
mobilisation qui a eu lieu également ce
week-end 2000 à 3000 personnes ont
répondu ce dimanche après midi à la
manifestation organisée par les élus de
loups ciel une manifestation pour dire
non à l'accueil des migrants si une
partie des élus souhaitait demander plus
de concertation avec l'état d'autres ont
tenu un discours plus tranché en
établissant un lien avec la menace
terroriste pour le moment les
discussions avec le préfet se
poursuivent et on notera également que
la fédération socialiste des yvelines
vient un communiqué dénonce je cite
l'attitude honteuse de certains élus de
droite qui dégradent l'image de notre
département nous appelons les élus
locaux à travailler en bonne
intelligence avec les différents acteurs
conclut sandrine grand gaube la
responsable du ps local du sport
également dans l actualité avec vous le
savez ce week end la ryder cup la plus
grande compétition de golf au monde qui
se déroulait aux états unis dans le
minnesota et dont deux ans les meilleurs
golfeurs se donneront rendez vous à
saint quentin en yvelines l'événement a
donc été suivi sur notre territoire et
pour faire découvrir ce sport jugés
parfois élitiste se tenait simultanément
ce week end le golf estivale sur le site
du golf national
le reportage d'haussmann vendeurs des
deux nicolas kirilow it
le geste n'est pas encore parfait la
technique hésitante mais l'objectif
n'était pas là pour la cinquième édition
du golfe festival l'événement se voulait
ludique faire découvrir la pratique d'un
sport sujet aux préjugés alors que dans
deux ans se profile la ryder cup à saint
quentin la plus grande compétition de
golf au monde dans deux ans on accueille
le troisième événement sportif le plus
médiatisé au monde
il ya plus de 600 millions de
téléspectateurs et donc ça va faire
venir énormément de gens il ya 80 mille
personnes par jour qui vont venir sur le
golf national donc c'est juste pour que
les gens aient des notions de ce sport
qu'ils puissent du coup en profite et
bien comprendre tout l'intérêt de tout
l'intérêt de cet évènement qu'est la
ryder cup pour sa cinquième édition le
goal festival a réuni près de 400
personnes découverte du site ou encore
pratique pour les débutants petits ou
grands étaient ravis de cette première
sur le green disons que la première fois
on touche pas du tout la balle est
beaucoup plus amusant qui va c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment une technique
et on n'est pas forcément habitué c'est
vraiment sympa c'est c'est agréable ça
détend je prie sais pas ce que c'est
c'est marrant à savoir entamer dans une
valve après on a comme j'en avais jamais
fait j'avais pas trop ce que ça donnait
en tout cas c'est vraiment des choses
que j'ai aimé c'était bien en france
près de 800000 personnes pratiquent
régulièrement le golf un chiffre qui
devrait augmenter d'ici 2018 et la
prochaine édition de la ryder cup
l'ambiance était sportive également hier
à montigny le bretonneux ou 400 coureurs
de la ville se sont affrontés lors d'un
trail urbain à travers la ville créée
l'an dernier l'événement propose cinq
épreuves pour les enfants pour les
adultes l'une d'entre elles est réservé
aux personnes polyhandicapées
accompagnés par des adultes valides ces
jeunes ont pu le temps de la course
goûter aux joies de la compétition
anne-laure languit les images de
haussmann wandern et
c'est parti pour trois kilomètres de
course pas question de traîner pour ces
sept jeunes polyhandicapés leurs
accompagnants venu ce matin d'un centre
de cergy pontoise le sport est pour eux
un moyen de se relier au monde extérieur
ça permet aux résidants d'être comme
nous dans le monde dans la société donc
pas de participer à ce qui existe dans
les communes et puis c'est important
aussi pour pour les professionnels de
pouvoir être eux aussi dans une
dynamique d'inclusion pas facile de
pousser les fauteuils en courant alors
chacun à travailler sa technique à une
ou deux mains malgré la chaleur les
équipes ont su garder le rythme avec une
moyenne de 10 km heure sur tout le
parcours aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
raison d'isoler le handicap du reste de
la vie et en fait nous mettons en avant
le sport à travers le sport est aussi
pour les valides mais c'est aussi une
activité pour les handicapés et c'est ce
que nous voulons mettre en valeur
[Applaudissements]
à l'arrivée joie et soulagement pour
tout le monde les premiers ont franchi
la ligne après 14 minutes de course les
suivants se sont battus jusqu'au bout
encouragé par le public avec le succès
des jeux paralympiques les organisateurs
espèrent attirer un plus grand nombre de
coureurs et de public l'an prochain
loisirs dimanche c'était la
traditionnelle fête des vendanges elle
encourt pour cette édition la récolte a
été moins fructueuse que pour les
précédentes les vignes ont souffert des
intempéries qu'a connues la région elle
les membres de l'association les amis du
passé d'elancourt espère produire une
quarantaine de bouteilles au lieu des
120 habituellement comme chaque année
les élans courtois était invitée
récolter les grappes de raisin et parmi
les ramasseurs vous le voyez des jeunes
enfants pour les écoutes au micro de
mélanie poker tu prends le raisin de la
main gauche si tu es tu prends la la
passe et tu peux plus couple atom ça et
après tu le dépose délicatement dans le
panier kabbara on peut boire manger et
se boucle en blé la luz en sait un peu
amusant et puis c'est bon allez manger
jean prince les plus beaux et puis les
autres
je laisse pour les oiseaux qui rime
hinges ceux qui sont abîmés un tout
autre loisir à présent celui des jeux
vidéo jouets ou plutôt rejouer à la game
boy ou encore à la megadrive en un
plaisir toujours d'actualité malgré
l'ancienneté de ses consoles les jeux
vidéo anciennes générations ont toujours
la cote et ce n'est pas de l'association
mo5 qui dira le contraire ce week end
elle a organisé notamment aussi une
exposition de retrogaming à la verrière
nous sommes allés rencontrer ces
passionnés
[Musique]
25 ans de carrière et 70 millions de
jeux vendus sonic le hérisson de sega
n'a pas pris une ride and à verrières
les amateurs de vieilles consoles ont pu
se replonger dans les jeux vidéo
ancienne génération
un rendez vous pour les plus jeunes mais
aussi les plus grands les papas les
mamans qui ont joué au concert quand ils
étaient petits qui peuvent jouer avec
leurs enfants et faire découvrir des
consoles locale il a auquel il jouait à
eux quand il était petit et on sait ce
qui est très drôle c'est de voir que les
enfants ont tout de suite là bas ils
s'adaptent tout de suite à la console
quoi c'est intuitif chez eux c
c'est très drôle de les voir jeux
gamecube megadrive super nintendo des
consoles devenu culte des personnages
emblématiques une passion pour les vieux
jeux qui a un nom le retrogaming
patrick est un habitué de cette pratique
il a installé trois écrans pour
s'adonner à son passe-temps portables ou
de salon une dizaine de consoles
différentes occupent son appartement
la plus vieille que j'ai je pense ça va
être la playstation donc est sorti en
europe en 1995 je crois là c'est tomb
raider le premier sur la première
playstation
c'est le plaisir de rejouer à des des
jeux auxquels j'avais pu jouer à
l'époque quand j'étais ado
ensuite il ya aussi le fait de pouvoir
les redécouvrir
avec soin une meilleure qualité d'image
soit sur des écrans différents
sa connexion a pris forme au fil des
années grâce aux dons de ses amis le
retro gaming une forme de nostalgie qui
peut atteindre des sommes
impressionnantes
certains jeux sont vendus plus de 1000
euros même avec le succès des nouvelles
versions la première lara croft a encore
de beaux jours devant elle elle fête
cette année ses 20 ans
certains vivent dans le passé d'autres
vivent plutôt dans le futur le 29
septembre dernier l'estaca école
d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans les
nouvelles mobilités accueillait
l'événement smart manufacturing paris
saclay 2016 l événement qui permet aux
élèves de rencontrer des professionnels
thème principal de cet événement la
voiture de demain on écoute le directeur
innovation et partenariats de
l'établissement
aujourd'hui physiquement il ya beaucoup
de révolutions le véhicule du futur à la
fois il est révolutionnée par son usage
on va parler des voitures particulières
mais aussi de mode de véhicules partagés
un autre quel usage on va parler de
technologie à bord qui est service
vas y trouver en termes de systèmes
embarqués de connectivité et de services
à bord et puis on va aussi réfléchir des
nouveaux véhicules les véhicules de
demain qui vont pouvoir consommer plus
propre qui vont pouvoir consommer
autrement avec d'autres sources
d'énergie propos recueillis par
haussmann vendeurs d'habits merci de
nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver sur le
www.td.com 18 points comme et puis vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux je
vous retrouve demain mardi 18 heures
pour une toute nouvelle édition
[Musique]